dans le dossier judiciaire du
chlordécone il aura fallu beaucoup de
patience et de ténacité aux avocats à
l'origine trois plaintes majeurs sont
déposées contre x pour tenter de
déterminer les responsabilités dans ce
désastre sanitaire de en martinique une
en guadeloupe
celle de martinique entre 2006 et 2007
émane de la sopam art pour
empoisonnement et mise en danger de la
vie d'autrui et d'écologie urbaine de
louis boutrin pour empoisonnement ce que
nous attendons de cet ouvrage
maintenant que nous avons établi les
responsabilités c'est que qu'il y ait
des enquêtes épidémiologiques par des
experts indépendants
deuxièmement nous voulons que les
agriculteurs les petits agriculteurs
notamment cuisson également victimes de
ces situations soient indemnisés
l'avocat se base notamment sur les
travaux réalisés avec raphaël confiant
dans le livre qu'il présente alors
chronique d'un empoisonnement annoncé en
guadeloupe
c'est une association de consommateurs
l'ufc qui porte plainte en 2006 pour
administration de substance nuisible et
mise en danger de la vie d'autrui
les trois plaintes rencontre de nombreux
obstacles voir des péripéties
[Applaudissements]
car entre temps quand paraît a récupéré
le dossier une pièce a été égaré sa
disparition pourrait entraîner un vice
de procédure mais depuis 2013 les choses
semblent s'accélérer
les trois plaintes ont été réunis en un
seul dossier chez le même juge
d'instruction au tribunal de grande
instance de paris les avocats ont été
reçus la semaine dernière avec des
nouvelles plutôt encourageantes
le dernier juge d'instruction en charge
du dossier a décidé de donner une autre
orientation à la quête en demandant aux
gendarmes d'identifier physiquement les
personnes qui dans les ministères en
travailler sur le cul ol-om le kepone
qui ne sont qu des dénominations
commerciales du chlordécone de
d'identifier les importateurs
distributeurs revendeurs et lobbystes
d'identifier également les groupements
hommes de planteurs et autres qui ont pu
utiliser de façon illicite le
chlordécone après l'interdiction les
noms des acteurs présents à cette époque
sont déjà connus
les ministre edith cresson michel rocard
ou encore jean pierre soisson les
groupements de planteurs gifam
et si kabam l'importateur laurent de la
garrigue et certains hommes politiques
en martinique
mais si leur relation avec le
chlordécone est un fait leur éventuelle
culpabilité ne peut être déterminé que
par l' enquête et le tribunal nous
devrions en savoir plus dès la semaine
prochaine